welcome to episode 66 of the michaela
peterson podcast
this was the second episode with my good
friend michael malus
he's probably my top 10 favorite people
hopefully he doesn't watch this intro
don't need him to hear that
we covered a bunch of fairly random
topics some talk about russia
self-publishing anarchy the usual
michael malus if you don't know him is a
new york city-based
author podcaster columnist media
personality
and anarchist this episode is brought to
you by self-authoring
self-authoring was developed by my dad
over the last 30 years with help from
two other phd's at mcgill and harvard
it has past authoring allowing you to
write out your past
great for trying to work through trauma
although i'd recommend writing about
trauma
at minimum a year after it's gone so you
don't re-traumatize yourself
it has present authoring which helps you
write out your present and identify
flaws that you can work on figuring out
and future authoring which helps you
make a plan for the future
with codemp you get 10 off at self
authoring.com if you don't have a goal
you have nothing to aim for
this helps fix that selfauthoring.com
codemp
i hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
so
michael malus welcome back to my podcast
thank you michaela
it's very nice to see you again i like
your haircut
can i call you carnivore barbie now
i prefer trump spokeswoman barbie
that was kind of amazing or cd for short
cb uh i do hope it sticks
yeah i i i i was a little
surprised how mean girlsy that what
we're referring to is that article that
was written by the times about your dad
that you made that video about i watched
it i just had lauren chen on the show we
talked about a little bit
as well uh how um a lot of it just
seemed to be about making
do you know you're young do you know
what baby jane is
no okay so okay sit back
so there was this movie in like 1960 or
1962
called whatever happened to baby jane
and it starred joan crawford
and uh betty davis and they were both
older like at that point like has been
actresses
and the premise of the movie is that
joan crawford was in a wheelchair
and she's trapped under the care of her
sister who's increasingly going insane
and she can't leave the house and
there's this one very famous scene
and they hate each other in real life
and it really comes through in the movie
and there's this one scene
where joan crawford says to her you know
jane you wouldn't be treating me this
terribly if i wasn't stuck in this
wheelchair
and she like pauses and she goes but you
are blanche
you are in that chair and you're never
getting out of it and she like locks her
in the room
so like that article was really like
your dad is your prisoner and like
you're doing all these things to him
as he's at your crazy mercies that's how
it came off to me
yeah and i was so upset
i've had a number of like hit pieces
come out especially about the carnivore
diet and sure how insane it is
and i can usually laugh them off
especially if it's like daily mail or
something
this one really hurt and that made me
really angry because i couldn't even get
mad at anyone in person i couldn't call
someone and yell at them
on the phone it was just this like
entity that i had
couldn't communicate with and i was so
angry because during the interview that
i had with her
i said honestly not not even close to
one of the hardest things but
one of the things that's been very
difficult is i've
been attacked online from these trolls
saying i've taken over my dad's business
i have him in the basement and i'm
killing him and it was like on top of my
dad
almost dying and taking a lot of risks
which paid off
but that was really hard emotionally so
i told her i straight up told her that
i was like i'm trying to get the story
out about what happened because
that's and she even she even brought it
up right she said this must have been
really hard on you
right and then got me to tell that story
and then just did exactly the same thing
that all these people that
i was just like why but also the whole
thing
any health issue is you're dealing with
a lot of uncertainty so it takes like
a lot to be like am i doing the right
thing like we're leaving the country
like yeah crazy am i stupid like maybe i
am you know and you're only gonna know
at the end
but while yeah and you're like okay
maybe how is it
what are the odds that i a barbie doll
know what i'm talking about and all
these people don't it's going to be
pretty low
so yeah there's that's going to add to
it
that's that definitely adds the stress
especially if you're getting told by
everyone
i mean we had family discussions about
leaving the country so family flew down
and we all sat around the table and
we're like
this is totally [ __ ] up like
is this really the best option [ __ ] this
is the best option
okay because if this goes sideways like
we can't we can't
lay all the blame and have our family
fracture right
like we really need to be in on this
together so that did happen but because
i was the one who went
and because my husband speaks russian
then it landed on me
but she certainly didn't help yeah
but it's also kind of like as if your
dad is just completely
you know possible who is not he's not
jordan peterson well it was basically
like a three-year-old
like an incubator that that's part of
the problem i have too it's like you're
forcing him to
like to to have a diet like yeah i'm
i've how do you even do that to somebody
like how could i do that he's literally
chained in my basement there's no other
way that that could work
like what are you guys assuming he has
no control over himself
or no ability to think critically or
like is he yeah and he's
an educated intelligent person right
yeah
so yes but i do hope the barbie doll
part sticks at least there's not i read
that and i was just like that's
weird that's a weird thing to just throw
in there
that's very strange barbie's
accomplished isn't the whole point of
barbie that every girl wants to grow up
to be her
yeah i think so they changed her she's a
doctor she's president
uh she's in a wheelchair that doesn't
fit into her house
uh she's a businesswoman she's she's
everything a lion tamer probably
i haven't seen that doesn't fit into her
house barbie oh that's the thing there's
a wheelchair
it's not really barbie it's like cricket
or whatever her name is but she doesn't
fit through the barbie cricket
house she barbie's got a little friend
there's a i forgot the friend's name i
don't know
there's a sister skipper right or
something
i have no idea i didn't like barbie i
remember i got bought barbies as a
kid and then there was this one dress
and it had one of those chokers at the
top
but they hadn't made a sticky thing for
the choker to open so it was just a loop
and it couldn't fit over her head and i
was
i was four i remember this when i was
living boston and i couldn't get this
dress on with the choker and i was like
this is this is a mess whoever designed
this
didn't make a didn't make the neck part
sticky i can't even open it i'm done
with barbies
and now you got your revenge apparently
i've been waiting a long time for this
george peterson should have gotten me a
he-man
that's very true i like your uh michael
malus
over your shoulder in the back uh that
was a fan
um got that for me it's the red pills
floating behind me
oh that's from though bishop
he sent it in the mail i'm like this is
really really cool that is cool
yeah and this is a vintage 1980s o piece
towel
ocean pacific you don't know what that
is you're too young but this was the
brand in the 80s before that's cool too
yes that was before i was born so you
were
you were just on rogan i was yeah
and what's his new studio like it's
weird because it doesn't seem to be on
brand for him
because it feels like a little like um
like a sci-fi set
for like something on the sci-fi channel
it's much smaller and more intimate
so one of the things i loved about the
la studio
is it was the room was very big it's
still an intimate setting and that
you've done the show obviously
the thing that about that show which is
um hard for people to grasp
is you forget that there's an audience
uh because it's not
it's yeah like it's like a room it's not
like us looking at a mod or something
and then it goes on for so long you
can't really stay on
for that long and as soon as you leave
or at least for me i'm like oh crap what
did i say
and you also because he's like this is
his house you have to be reacting to him
as opposed to like here
like we're more like collegial so you're
also kind of like there's that joke
about fred astaire and ginger rogers
like
everything he did she had to do
backwards and in high heels so
you're kind of like reacting to where
that's where i figured that out after my
third appearance like you have to
follow his lead because if you think
you're gonna drive the car it's just
gonna be a disaster
uh and it's gonna go all over the place
to come prepared with that stuff
and then you leave and you're like okay
i have no memory of what i said and i'm
like oh crap
okay and nothing got me in trouble this
time thankfully
that's exactly the experience i had i
thought maybe it was just me
it was about an hour in i thought it was
the fluorescent lighting that he had at
the top and about an
hour and 20 minutes in i was like oh no
i can't even remember i can't remember
where i started this sentence
it's like oh this is not good and at the
time i wasn't really aware of
how large joe rogan's audience was and i
was like well i
can't remember the last half of the
conversation okay i thought that was
just me
huh yeah yeah and then people are like
oh thanks for the shout out i'm like oh
i'm glad i got that in like
when ben dominance is like thanks for
the shout out i'm like i don't know how
i brought you up i'm glad i did we're
boys you're the best
so yeah yeah i had someone ask me to do
a shout out
when you know when i got on rogan and
you're right there was no
directing the conversation yeah i
actually had my little
business card of things i wanted to hit
and as soon as those segways came up i
was in there
and i got them all taken care of so that
was good
that's very prepared yeah i i i wasn't
gonna
waste time smart no business cards today
because we're pals
yeah that's fine that's totally fine
uh what was what was traveling during
the pandemic like did you have to get
tested a bunch of times
did you have to get tested to do the
podcast yeah so he had a nurse i put on
my instagram like sitting in the
uh entry entry room like people think
it's at his house it's not his house
that was his studio i thought that was i
don't know what i thought the airport or
something no no that was at a studio
there's a girl
a nurse i don't say girl uh and she does
this
quick test i didn't know this was a
thing where she just swabs the inside at
the very
tip of the inside of your nostril both
of them and 15 minutes later you get a
result so i learned
i don't have cobia and i am pregnant
it's going to be a demon child it's kind
of here comes the end
here come the end times sorry about it
the end times are
here in my opinion
so they had a test where they don't jam
it up your nose
where do where are those those aren't in
canada yet
or at least no one's telling me about
them oh this the quick test i i this is
the first i'd heard about
it hmm i wanted to bring
scarlet i wanted to escape from toronto
because it's really not fun here
it's like dark and cold like winter time
in toronto is
but everyone's left downtown there are
tents around
and we're in like a mandated lockdown
where only essential businesses are open
yeah very very depressing i went
into so i went downtown into yorkville
which is our
uh which is the kind of it's the
expensive area that has fancy little
shops in toronto
and there was a cop going from
store to store listening to make sure
people aren't doing
a legal business even though you can
still do curbside pickup
but there was legitimately a cop going
door to door
listening to make sure people weren't
operating illegally
one of the greatest things that's
happened in the past year as you know
i'm an anarchist
i have never seen any group change their
opinion on a core
issue so quickly as the conservatives on
the police because two years ago
they would be tripping over themselves
to defend the police against any
criticism
and they were right to do so because of
the criticisms like cops are racist it's
like it's not really disproportionate
you know in terms of crime but when you
see
the cops like in it was in canada
pulling like older people at their home
if you saw in belgium they were telling
a clear park and there's a cop on a
horse
clubbing an old man it's really hard to
be like and these aren't the bad apples
the ones who get bribes
these are the good apples these are the
ones who are actually doing their job
the bad apples are the ones that take
bribes right but they're
they're the good ones now yeah yeah yeah
and i had that quote i said there's
no law so obscene and this is from your
that book your dad always recommends
or amen i said there's no law so obscene
that the police would be unwilling to
enforce them up to it including the
summary execution of
innocent children so you know this
fantasy americans have that
oh if the law got too crazy the cops
would refuse to enforce it
we're seeing it like this like what
would it take for like here's just a
simple example
i don't even mean like shooting
criminals like i think we could wrap our
heads around that we're shooting people
who you regard as a threat
but like what would it take for just
anyone listening to this
for you to go to like a six-year-old
girl a cute girl who has a lemonade
stand
and forced her to tear it down like i
there's no amount of money that would
let me do something about the clear
conscience and they do that on a daily
basis
as well as enforcing laws i know it's
not part of canadian culture but in
america the second amendment
i can't have a gun in new york i'm
unsafe because of you
and you and it's just brazenly unlawful
uh things that are passed by congress
and they don't care they're just
doing their job which is when you
absolve yourself of moral responsibility
you void a very essential element of
what it means to be human in my opinion
it's pretty screwed up right now it's
funny
conservative so i agree everyone was up
in arms about defund the police
but conservatives are saying let us keep
our guns
and keep the police and liberals are
saying no guns
no police and you're saying
keep the guns no police yeah
because right and or have private
security
or to have private security well i'm all
for that at the moment
because right now things are not good in
canada
like people really are getting arrested
for doing things that
shouldn't be illegal just because
somebody mandated it as illegal
and there's no from my understanding you
know having talked to lauren chen this
week
it seems like there's absolutely no
possibility or trajectory for this to
get
better at least in the medium term yeah
i mean they
they say okay so in ontario technically
in ontario they've moved
certain areas to a zone where more
things are open
like if you go two and a half hours
north
uh restaurants are open limited capacity
but they're open
so it's not like we're gonna be locked
down like we are in toronto or montreal
forever
uh in in toronto the lockdown's been
extended until march 8th
i don't think it'll be forever but i
don't see
the the hotels or the quarantine coming
into canada going away i don't see the
masks going away
but and i don't know about the lockdown
but i would assume that that's going to
let out
let off about march but then i also read
there's a third wave
third wave or on third wave or fourth
ways there's some wave that's coming up
and we can see it it's coming and we
definitely think there'll be a lockdown
then
meanwhile we're still in a lockdown
they'll be like there's another lockdown
even though one hasn't ended i was like
god i gotta get out of this country so
this is what i was saying i wanted to
bring scarlett and
andre down to florida or texas we were
gonna go to houston
dodged a bullet on that one um so
we were going to go to houston or tech
or florida and then it turns out
in order to get into the u.s you need to
do these covid tests
and they swab anyone above the age of
two yeah and i was like i don't know
i know that i know that people get they
get coveted tests and
they do that all the time but like i'm
pretty anxious about
pinning down my three and a half year
old and having someone i don't know
stick something up her nose yeah no i
hear it
i hear you i remember when i was a kid
you know like anything coming at my face
you're gonna have this very
disproportionate fight-or-flight
reaction and then
just completely lose it uh yeah also
that's it's just it's just viscerally
uncomfortable for
you know at any point yeah anyway but
she had covid
like we all had coveted so it's so
aggravating and it's like
they show you on these government
websites well wrap your arms and legs
around your child to like keep them
still i was like yeah well what happens
if they move really quickly in the wrong
direction
do you know what you should do like in
all seriousness why don't you
practice at home with like a q-tip for
like five seconds and give him candy
that's what that's what people suggested
yeah
is like start with a q-tip and just be
very gentle and be like
it's not a big deal just relax he's
gonna do it watch me do it you know yeah
yeah yeah and that's what they suggested
which is if anyone needs to test
a tiny kid that is what i would
recommend is try and normalize it but
it's so angering that i was like maybe
we'll go to costa rica instead but at
this point i'm staying
i'm staying what i was saying is that
even if these lockdowns change
the principle that the state can at any
moment shut down your business and keep
in your home
that seems to be something that a lot of
uh weak and bad people have come to
accept in the same way that like world
war one in america
paved the way for the new deal because
they get because the first was during
the great war you can understand why the
government has taken over everything i
don't think that was necessary but
you know it makes some kind of sense
you're fighting the war to end all war
so when the great depression hit fdr
could be like look we just did this 20
years ago 15 years ago
i'm not asked you know now we're having
a war on you know bad economy i'm not
asking you anything you haven't done
before
so it's i don't think anyone can argue
that it'll be very hard for them to say
uh well
you need to be shut down your house for
certain hours to fight global warming
or to fight x-fight or to fight
terrorism or just whatever it is like
you've done it once it's just like with
your kid it's like okay you had the
little q-tip
now we're having a little different kind
of q-tip what are you complaining about
you just
you survived this you're fine you're not
the one who died so what are you
complaining about you know i lost my
grandma
do you want to lose you get it yeah
speech
i do get it and i think that's more
likely than not
yeah um so if we're going to talk about
solutions here
is the solution to just find a place
this doesn't exist and move there
or is there something people can change
because i'm a little bit of a pessimist
in this
situation i'm a pessimist in the short
term but i'm a very big optimist in the
long term
and the reason i'm an optimist in the
long term is
it's harder and harder to maintain a
narrative that's semi-detached from
reality
the longer it goes on because there's a
big asymmetry between a truth and a lie
like a murderer if you kill someone once
you're a murderer right
well you're not killing someone every
day like the rest of the year you could
be perfectly nice and giving kids
candy and trick trick-or-treat and then
you're santa at the mall but you kill
one person that situation is permanently
changed who you are as a human being
so if you are an organization like the
corporate press
whose job is ostensibly to inform people
but if you're caught
you know in not just mistruths but lie
after lie after lie depending on the
individual
that's when the trust is lost some
people are skeptics by nature it's just
gonna take one and they're like all
right i'm out
some people it's gonna take a hundred
some people will never reach that point
and they can't be reached and that's
fine
but the longer it goes on uh trust once
lost is almost impossible to regain
and i think the kind of thing where it's
like we have to be locked in our homes
now we have to be taken to the streets
to protest police brutality
now we have to be locked in our homes
again or cnn you know the day after
trump
leaving office removing the covet
counter uh
from their screen things like this like
once you point these things out that
there is clearly an agenda
um you know it becomes easier and easier
to red pill people but of course some
people
can't be reached because they don't want
to be they want to be in the matrix uh
h l menken had this great quote about
how the average man does not want to be
free he simply wants to be safe
and there's a lot of people who resent
people who question authority
because that forces them to have to make
these choices and they gave that up
they're like look
i handed this over have the screens tell
me what to do i'll be obedient
and you'll keep me safe but me forcing
you to think
that breaks the whole deal it's like
when a husband finds out that um
or a wife your spouse found out they're
like cheating and it's like i want it to
look the other way
now that the mistress confronted me you
ruined kind of the deal
and and the anger is often at the person
who informed as opposed to
yeah the actual mistress or the wife or
the husband yeah
yeah yeah that's very true the only
problem with that is
that like this kind of thing can still
last for a really long time
like even if you look at what happened
in the soviet union
it was like it decades oh yeah that's
yes
that's the topic of my next book yeah
yeah so if it's that kind of thing then
is it better to move
i know someone i i just had him on the
podcast i haven't published the episode
cesar santos he's this portrait artist
and he moved from cuba to the u.s when
he was a kid
to avoid communism and he just moved
with his family
and he was he was like this place is
going to [ __ ]
i think he moved to somewhere in france
which doesn't
i feel like there are some issues there
but it wasn't it was outside of a major
city
just on some farmland he's just like i'm
out of here but he said that the
similarities he saw were too much so he
moved again after like 40 years in the
states
uh i can see why he would say that um
but i think
this is kind of their last gasp
um and i i'm not thinking it's gonna go
anywhere remotely close to like
venezuela or the soviet union
so i should still move to texas but
maybe not houston
texas or florida everywhere everyone's
going that's why i was just in austin
for a week to
all my oh my whole crew i have one
friend left in new york they're all gone
okay in austin do you like it
uh i did not i first of all um
as i'm sure you can appreciate to have a
whole group of people
who are like we will do whatever it
takes to get you to move here
and like to be that um welcomed
is something few people get to have and
it was really
very very emotionally moving so like any
objection i had and these were actual
concerns like i don't know how to drive
my friends like i will teach you how to
drive
like i promise my other friend doesn't
know how to drive she goes we'll learn
together i'm like okay
i've got a huge ton of books and my
other friend jay goes
okay you're just gonna have to write out
a big check like it sucks
like moving sucks but these are books
these aren't chandeliers
you're going to have some big dudes
they're going to put them in boxes and
they'll move the boxes so it's just
going to be a financial hit
and that's not really a reason to be
like i'm going to be trapped in misery
for 20 years
because i can't write out this big check
once put on your credit card if you have
to
um so those were kind of like and
i didn't realize how like the rents
there are like half
here in new york and my buddy's like you
want that like brooklyn
bachelor pad loft like on gossip girl
like in new york it's eight grand
there would be like 2500 which is not
cheap but when you compare these two
numbers i don't need that
that bachelor pad my friend has a two
bedroom it's just like amazing he's got
laundry
it's just things that everyone america
takes for granted as a new yorker you're
like oh like my other friend has a house
you know like if i was going to get a
house i want to i want stairs so i can
go upstairs i've never had had that in
my life
going upstairs and downstairs but at the
same time what i didn't like about
austin
is there aren't these little
neighborhoods like in new york or even
in la or philly or
or toronto certainly or boston where you
could just walk around for like an hour
and there's cool little shops and
but that's nowhere i can't find that on
earth anymore
because those were the first victims of
this
lockdown is all those little unique
stores who did not have the financial
wherewithal
to survive for a year with no revenue
i'm sure they were marginal at the time
anyway
so you know like they they there's this
essay by
f scott fitzgerald you know who was
obviously the big author of the 1920s
who captured the jazz age which he named
and it was after the the stock market
crashed in 1929
and he's just his it's he's just
heartbroken like begging for new york to
come back
and it wouldn't come back in his
lifetime it wouldn't come back probably
like for another
20 years so i i it's it's
it's like i'm in love with a place that
no longer exists
and i don't know what plan b is we're
going to be spending a week in miami
because i hear that's the other
place that everyone's moving to uh next
month we're gonna have a road trip
um so we'll see if that works out but
come to
i gotta tell you if you're thinking
about it if you're asking my opinion
because i know we respect each other
i would tell you get the f out of canada
because it looks like it's going to get
much worse there before it gets here
um yeah okay well a couple of years ago
i was looking at
i was looking at la actually but i'm not
looking at la anymore
no um and then i was looking at austin
but i've been to austin and i thought
i'm so picky i really like toronto like
the streets are kind of narrow
yeah it's cool and i found austin was i
don't know it very well
so that's the main problem is i don't
know it went very well but the streets
were really wide and i didn't understand
the neighborhoods
i was like where's the where's the cool
this district
yeah i couldn't find it it's much more
suburban
and it's not a walking town so that's
something that you and i are gonna have
to have a problem with
oh and yeah and it's not a walking place
okay well let me know what miami's like
because i've heard that miami has a
really cool downtown
and i have friends moving to miami too
and that's why i wanted to go to
either houston or austin or miami to
kind of look around to gauge
where i want to move because i wanted to
move before
covet hit because i i don't really enjoy
the winter
yeah but it's also not i mean to be
locked in your home is for mental health
and being a mom it's not tenable in my
opinion no it's not and like
jesus i just spent 25 years getting my
mental health controlled
like it's controlled now and it's like
stay at home
stay inside like whoa this is slippery
so how about that and it's dark out and
i'm fortunate enough that i actually
moved from a house because i didn't like
the stairs
but this is this is when my ankle was in
really bad shape i was like these
stairs are too much for me so i moved to
a condo unfortunately i have a lot of
light
if i didn't have like i have a lot of
windows so if i didn't have the windows
then i don't know we'd probably be in
costa rica waiting it out but
i thought i could just kind of grind
down here for a while because
i have a lot of podcast opportunity and
we were traveling all
last year not for fun it's like i just
want a place to stay
for a while to stabilize but it's
impossible to stabilize somewhere where
you're stuck at home and you can't go
out like even just having a relationship
at home yeah is really hard if you can't
get a break
let's also uh not forget all those
people who aren't as fortunate as us
who don't have these options and my
heart breaks for them
where they like what they have some
roommate that they hate and they're with
them when they're young
or they just don't have the financial
resources to just pack up and move and
write that check for all those books
um it's i mean i'm not forgotten about
you people
and it's awful and i feel for you and
it's just
these are the in many ways uh you know
covet obviously has the
literal people who died but the
secondary victims family members who
you know couldn't say goodbye to mom or
go to her funeral people who are trapped
in their homes who have no social outlet
and haven't had one for a while
and are now starting to kind of
degenerate and disintegrate
like these people need to be kind of
recognized and
obviously i know you think about that as
well yeah i certainly do that's part of
the reason i've been talking
about it because i'm like if you're
already
in an unstable situation you don't need
any more instability and this is a lot
of instability and it's
literally killing people yes and for
some reason it was like
the left is so hyper
focused on those people in those
unstable situations
and then kovid came and it was like oh
[ __ ] you guys you're just trying to make
everyone else sick
yeah it was like what happened to
thinking about the people who have no
money
or who are in relationships that they
shouldn't be in stuck in that house like
what happened to you thinking about
those people
now they're bad guys because they want
to go to work it's so aggravating
yeah i talked about this in my books and
you write how
you might be old enough to remember this
at one point there was this huge
anti-bullying campaign
and then it was like you have to not
bully these nerds it's really
messed up it screws it up for a long
time then gamergate happened
and all the video gamers and all the
nerds turned their
attacks on the cathedral and this kind
of left the hegemony
and then right away those kids you
shouldn't bully were all potential
school shooters
and it was simply a matter of defying
what the narrative was
to go from you have to be protected your
victims
to you are one minute away from being
mass murderers and need to be oppressed
overnight i i was just talking about
that i can't remember who i was talking
about it with but i was talking about
how
oh it was rav aurora he's been writing
art he's like 20 he's been writing
articles for the national
or new york post um that are more
a geared towards right wing crowd i
would say
but he's smart he's only 20. and i had
him on and i was saying when i was
younger um there wasn't any anti-racist
stuff there was a ton of anti-bullying
yeah
and my dad was always grumbling about
this anti-bullying stuff and i was
but i can remember in class it being
like it's showing the kid and it was
in in a book and it'd be like this fat
kid and everyone would be bullying him
because he was fat
which in reality is not why people got
bullied right fat kids didn't get
bullied at least not the school i was at
there was this kid he had a ear he had
hearing aids
in and he was bullied by this girl
terribly and i was like that's terrible
that's terrible
and so i tried to be friends with him
and he was
so mean he was he was confident he was a
year older than
me he was condescending and rude and i
was like
oh you're bullied because you're an
[ __ ] it has nothing to do with the
hearing aids
it's like yep and that was my experience
in elementary schools a lot of the
bullying came towards kids who were
mean not all the time yeah sometimes i
got a little bit of bullying in
different areas it's just like
it's a hierarchy pecking order thing but
there was a huge anti-bullying campaign
when i was
in elementary school for sure
yeah so do you have a new book coming
out i got two
you have two are you gonna publish them
you're not publishing them at the same
time
i am not um uh one of my supporters
marla she had the great idea
people always ask me if i want to learn
more about anarchism what could i do
and i'm always like i don't know don't
bother me like i figured it out
and then she's like the the last book
that was like this was a book from 1966
called patterns of anarchy
and it's just it was this hard to find
paperback and it's a collection of all
these essays
from like the anarchists of you know
back in the day
and i'm like wait a minute this is like
public domain these people are like
dead for a century so i'm just compiling
a collection
of all the different schools of
anarchism in like the anarchist reader
the anarchist handbook and you could
just sit down and understand the
philosophy from every angle
so that's going to be really quick to
that's going to be
wildly popular yeah because so many more
people like wait a minute we need to
have alter are realizing
how nefarious government is even at you
know
ostensibly free country um and
the other one is the white pill which is
you know why the good guys won and why
we're going to win again
but that's a i'm halfway done it's going
to be very very very intense
why will win again that sounds like a
book people need right now yeah
everyone's like i need your book i need
your book well i'm like yeah well it's
really hard
you know if i'm if i'm reading like 50
pages to get a paragraph
it's glacial because i'm very big on
having as much content as
uh possible yeah that's good
um chris williamson told me that
andrew doyle's new book was it's just 90
pages but apparently it's 90 pages of
solid uh solid writing there isn't any
fluff
so apparently that's good yeah we'll see
maybe i'll talk to him again
um one of you you mentioned the anarch
anarchy book and that
you don't have a handbook for and you're
like whatever i already figured it out i
had the same
similar issue with the carnivore diet
where i was like it's just it's like all
i eat is meat there we go problem solved
yeah but how and i was like i've got
youtube videos like i talk about it
spread out every 60 seconds in 10 000
hours like
i know it's not not very digestible but
i think that anarchy book's gonna a
really good idea
especially now oh yeah and it's really
gonna bother the anarcho-communists
because they don't like the
anarcho-capitalist they don't think it's
real anarchism and they have a point
because it is in many ways
antithetical to the original kind of
anarchism um
but too bad i'm going to be the one
who's going to be kind of mainstreaming
this term
and the expression i have is the black
flag has many colors so
all the schools are going to be
represented there and a lot of it
contradicts the other stuff but
you know you when you eliminate the
state
you know there's many different
possibilities of what the results going
to look like
and i think it's kind of specious to say
well it's definitely going to look like
this or it's definitely gonna look like
that
what's the difference between anarcho
and what did you say anarcho-capitalism
versus
anarcho-communism so the first
anarchists were communists
so they they view the government as a
mechanism
of oppression but they think that when
the state is removed
everyone will be equal and like work
well
right that's their that seems very
unlikely everyone will just be nice to
each other
like who do you think got into power in
the first place well their point is
people
aren't nice because they're forced to or
encouraged to be
by the state which renders them poor
and renders them disharmonious right so
that's one that's their
thesis which okay let them make their
point i'll have them at length
uh then the anarcho-capitalists think
when you remove the state
and you have um competition
you don't for example these these
rioting and looting if there was
competition among security
you wouldn't just have one police
monopoly you could say yeah we're just
going to sit in our hands
when the one time we need police is
happening and if your business gets
burnt down
well you got insurance as opposed to
when you have car insurance
right if your car gets broken they pay
for the repairs so in this case if you
had security insurance
the cops would be the ones who are
making you whole instead of being like
well your sol
uh you know there's not even a pretense
if your home gets burglarized
that the police are going to do anything
about it like that people even in
sitcoms
right which are don't it's an imaginary
story
when their house gets burglarized the
cops never pretend to find anything you
can't even imagine such a thing
happening
whereas in real life if i order
something from macy's
or or that local mom and pop store that
went out of business
and i don't get it i'm getting a refund
they're accountable until the customer
gets the service that was provided for
them so it's a complete uh inversion
of how the market and freedom operates
so well we cover there's a lot there to
cover because this has been a long
tradition um going back to i think i'm
going to start with
uh lysandre spooner then there were the
ones in the late 19th
19th century who are all about you know
building bombs and terrorism
and i have essays from them too you know
okay i think that's the one
i'm familiar with when i think of
anarchism that's what i think of
yeah i thought that the communism one
was just communism
no they're the ones who are saying we're
going to blow up the state since the
government is there to protect property
of the wealthy
and to keep the workers poor we're using
these bombs basically in self-defense
so once we they're there this is before
1917
so they were very much for this marxist
idea of revolution and they would train
in militias to try to you know get this
thing going
uh and in fact some of the first
anti-gun anti-gun rights laws
in america were passed in illinois
because you had labor unions
were drilling with guns in preparation
for
a revolution so like there's all this
kind of forgotten history which is fun
to unpack
and that's going to be in both books to
some extent cool
and when are they set to publish do you
have a eta i want them both out this
year
that anarchist book i'm flying through
it because it's it's not that much work
it's just knowing your history and
knowing who should be represented
letting them speak for themselves
are you self-publishing yeah of course
there's there's no
possibility that i would do either of
this with a
mainstream publisher i was trying to
convince dad to self-publish
not not his like his book deal is kind
of old so it's been since then it was
like anything else
just let us do it at home yeah i can do
it at home it'll it'd be so good
and he's still set in the
well if you publish with somebody like
penguin it brings you a certain amount
of respect he's right
yeah but they also take most of your
money and they also encourage you to do
interviews that make your daughter cry
yeah exactly
thank you so but but at the same time if
he's self-publishing as the new york
times is going to review him probably
not
on the other hand is do you want the new
york times to review him so who knows
they're not going to they're not
the chance of him being on the
best-selling list for the new york times
in my opinion
prove me wrong i hope i'm wrong i think
it's zero
he gets a hundred percent he didn't hit
the new york times bestseller list
not last time even though he was there
and they used the excuse that it was
because it was a canadian book published
originally in canada
no and our agent went back and said
what about all these other books that
hit the new york times best-selling list
that are from canada and they're like
well we don't do like
just so he wasn't on the new york times
best-selling lesson 12 rules for living
was not a new york times bestseller even
though it sold ins for life excuse me
even though it sold
like huge numbers what was the best
seller on amazon but that's not what i
mean i'm in new york specifically in new
york times
best seller wow
it sold 5 million copies
mazel tov for that that's amazing yeah
it's crazy
second best-selling audiobook of 2018 in
canada
sunday times it hit
wall street journal washington times usa
the new york state it was oh my god
you're telling the truth the new york
times
stated it was not that i doubted you but
the seat in writing you know what i mean
it was not
counted because it was published by a
canadian company
see according to random house canada the
book was handled properly
for the us market of course it was
handled properly it's not like this book
oh my
oh wow isn't that scary so
my guess i don't think it's going to
make the new york times best-selling
list we'll see it's out march 2nd we'll
see what happens
but it didn't last time and there was no
reason for it so why would it this time
and if that's the case what's the point
of going to a publishing house
if you have a following too i got
a very touching email from the publicist
and
this is something you know what it is
like when you and i
like i'm not oh my god jordan peterson i
don't get that way for most people you
know what i mean like
maybe if it was camille paulie or a
friendly witch i'd be like oh my god
but this email really got to me and i i
i spent some time thinking about why and
i don't know
and she just said hi michael jordan
peterson's next book is going on sale
march 2nd and he's asked me to send you
an early signed copy
and i'm sure she got a list and everyone
got that email but it still made me feel
so like
like i've arrived i don't know what it
was it was very kind of moving
and i told her no thanks i don't have
time for canadian crap
don't send it don't bother this is just
going straight to ebay
so that was very touching oh well that's
good
uh that no that note is from dad but i
didn't
compile okay still okay but it it is his
like it's his wording and everything um
and i thought
spread it amongst spread it amongst the
people that we know and like with
followings
that's the way to infiltrate the market
if you want marketing
you don't need you know point are they
gonna do billboards in the subway right
now
yeah so that's good okay well i'm glad
you're self-publishing i'm gonna
self-publish too i've already made up my
mind i have my dad on one side being
like well
you know you don't have a degree
and no one's going to take you as
seriously unless you're with
a publishing house plus he hasn't seen
very many books that are self-published
that are high quality yeah yeah
so it's tricky you have to put an effort
you don't want it like printed crooked
and
everything's on a slant and everything
and so it looks like
some people in their basement put it
together yeah so you have to
you have to try was your last book
self-published
yeah and it still pays my rent 2014 it
came out
damn yeah so that's the difference you
see
the last book was not supposed the new
right i mean the dear reader the north
korean book was that was 2000 january
30th 2014.
and it was self-published yes it was
kickstarter yeah
wow so you did kickstarter and then you
got what did you pay for an editor and
everything and uh no
my when you're doing it yourself like
and people believe in the cause
uh they will a lot of people like how
can i help so my buddy
uh no i paid him to design the cover my
other one my other friend took it from a
word document into
you know book layout which isn't that
hard if it's not graphics intensive
um i hired a publicist but i kind of
you know worked my rolodex um and this
was a subject that not that many people
knew about
so since i did my homework i had some
kind of
opportunity as a consequence of that and
you did kickstarter just to get
kind of a gauge on how many people were
interested and
yeah did you salad at a lower price for
kickstarter or no
nope and my point it was a higher price
so my point was this is like kind of a
proof of concept
so if i can't raise 30 grand on
kickstarter this book's
doa so there's no this would be my way
of knowing
if there is an audience for it already
and there was thankfully
hmm maybe i should do something like
that
yeah it's not a bad idea to have some
kind of special sign hardcover or
something
i can talk to you about it when you're
ready that's it it's we'll have that
comment okay
i think i will have that conversation
with you i've had a conversation with a
number of people who've self-published
so i'm kind of getting the scope of
things and some people
spend a whole bunch of money on an
editor and formatting for
kindle and turning it into an audiobook
and they really go
the kind of regular publisher root
uh and then some people do it all
themselves it depends
you you definitely need to do the
audiobook yourself
yeah yeah for sure i don't i hate i i
don't understand unless someone has like
an accent or something
how they would have someone else read
their book i don't get it
did you or have you heard
i'm gonna have to find her because i
can't remember give me one sec
kaylee mcinnamy
no you're idle
you're stylized park young me
oh yeah have you spoken with her what do
you think of her
oh youngby yeah she was just on my show
two weeks ago yeah you had her on oh
yeah you released the episode yet yeah
it's out
it's on youtube um we had a great great
talk
because i wasn't asking her the basic
questions the one-on-one questions that
she has gets asked a lot
of course but i mean that she needs that
because most people
have no concept of north korea um so i
mean her got a little deeper also about
her
assimilating to the states south korean
culture song bun which is their social
credit system which is kind of spreading
unfortunately to some extent so we
really had a good in-depth conversation
and i i
it was really funny because just like i
trolled you a couple of times when we've
been on each other's show
i opened the show by saying uh konichiwa
i think you people say
and people like this guy made a fool of
himself in the first three minutes it's
like yeah that's what's happening here
buddy yeah
so she got a good laugh so that it's
important but like
it's important for people to be able to
have a little bit of a humor not that
this is not an obscenity
on human rights but also like it's so
dark if you don't
uh recognize the absurdity of it it's
hard to take it all in psychologically
and especially when it's dealing with
asia in the west there's this
low-key racism like oh they're weird
they're crazy over there
and it's like sure maybe they're crazy
and how their language is vertical and
it's
glyphs but there's difference between
that and oh we eat like squid
and you know totalitarian oppression
from the second you're born you're crazy
and weird covers a very big
gamut and we would like it to be just
they have
what we would consider weird food as
opposed to these people are prisoners
and slaves and have been
for um close to 80 years now i couldn't
keep it light
i asked all the like the serious
questions like is there really no
internet you know like that those kind
of questions and then afterwards after
it ended i just cried
oh yeah well i've got my crying out of
the way when i was there
and you see how these people live and
how normal and boring they are
that's the thing that i really want
westerners to understand these aren't
robots these aren't martians
like these are like teenage girls who
giggle at you in the street when you
wave with them and grandmas with their
grandkids
and they tell each other jokes so it's
like this
is not that removed from you as you
would like to think
uh and i'm not saying that when they're
free they're gonna be this amazing
people they're gonna be fat guys on
their recliner
drinking their beer and eating their
fried chicken or kimchi whatever
and it's just gonna be like you and me
maybe not like you and me but
they're not special they're just human
um and this dehumanization
of the north korean people which happens
in south korea
uh you know very heavily on me and i
talked about it is
very very disturbing to me what happens
in south korea that they're just like
north koreans are completely different
oh they're garbage they're treated like
complete garbage they hear the accent
they're like okay i don't you're like
crap it's a very hierarchical society so
when they're shorter
i think the average north korean male is
like shoe stomach is like 5'4 something
crazy because of malnutrition
so she and south korea is probably one
of the most racist
countries on earth when i was in
high school my high school was half
asian stuyvesant new york the korean
kids wouldn't talk to like the chinese
kids like it was just not a thing
so she has no south korean friends she
has chinese friends she has american
friends
but like she's like imagine i don't i'm
sure maybe it's over there something
with alberta
but here like people who are like from
alabama they come to new york it's like
okay like
as soon as they open their mouth people
just disregard them and it's like they
just have an accent
you know there is still a person so and
maybe
yeah so it's it's very very sad plus
they go from having every minute of
their lives taken care of
to freedom but they didn't have an
upbringing
where they know how to make informed
choices so it's like what like you go to
a supermarket you've never been one
before
how are you supposed to know which
deodorant to buy or how are you supposed
to know
how to pick these fruit it's just like
it's a good it's a it's
a good problem to have but it's still a
problem and also
it to be destitute in a country where
everyone is so
kind of like consumerist also is not
good on the ego in the psychology
at least in north korea you know you
could look around you're like okay we
were all the same and now it's just like
i'm the bottom of the bottom
and i have no hope of that changing
that's not an easy pill to swallow
yeah um when when people who immigrate
come to
canada and then get picked on for not
knowing
english or having an accent or not
understanding where things are in the
supermarket it's just like
have you not thought about this at all
from their angle
it's like wherever they were living was
so shitty
this is preferable do you understand
that and
and not understanding your language has
nothing to do with how smart that person
is
having an accent because they were born
in a different place has nothing to do
with iq
so if you treat them like it does have
something to do with iq then
that says something about you not them
yeah it's it's i mean being an immigrant
myself is something i'm kind of keenly
aware of and it's
it's it's very disturbing to see i was
not nearly as keenly aware of it until
i started dating a russian yeah and he
was talking about russophobia and i was
like
i was dating a russian so obviously i
wasn't that russophobic and i was like
come on you know that's not that seems
like
that can't be real and then i started
seeing it a little bit and was like
oh yeah that's really not very cool
that's really making me angry um
and then if you do any traveling i mean
the other problem is most people in
north america don't go anywhere
if they go somewhere they go to the
caribbean and they stay in a resort
or they go to like western europe they
don't go anywhere else so they don't
understand what it's like to be treated
as a foreigner i'm going with chris
williamson to russia
for my birthday i've never been there
since i left as a kid
and we're bringing a videographer and
it's going to be completely epic
and hysterical by hysterical i mean i'm
going to be having nervous breakdowns
every five minutes
where are you gonna go we're going to
level where i was born in ukraine
and either saint petersburg or moscow or
both and i do not get on well with
russian people
um and it's going to russian people
don't get along well with russians yeah
yeah but when they hear my accent where
i sound like a dumb american there
there's there's they're all gonna have
an opinion about it they're all gonna
you know
be flapping their roosky gums and i'm
from brooklyn and i'm not having it so
it's it's i'm already having arguments
with people i haven't met
and it's it's it's going to be hilarious
to watch i know we're going to start it
with me looking at my closet my 30 pairs
of jeans
figuring out which ones are the right
ones to wear for my trip because denim
is such a symbolic thing
during the former soviet union times
when are you gonna go july 12th is the
birthday
so you're gonna get to st petersburg for
like white nights
oh is that really well that's in august
i think is when the sun barely ever goes
down and people party all the time
so it's gonna be yeah well it's not
gonna be august it's mid july we'll be
there probably i think for a week so
yeah it's gonna be insane that's gonna
be insane
yeah i've got some connections if you
need people
when we went like seriously we went to
there's a couple of scams there's one
scam that really hits people in saint
petersburg
and you'll go there and you'll make
friends with some girls
super friendly girls and you'll all go
to a bar and you'll drink
for a while and then you'll get the bill
and the bill will be like
it won't be insane but it'll be like
fifteen hundred dollars u.s
right so so a large bill and you'll go
that's weird like what
exactly did you order and they'll go
well they ordered these drinks you're
paying for them
they ordered these really expensive
drinks and they're affiliated with the
bar
yeah of course yeah and then if you
don't pay you literally get
beaten up by the dudes who own the bar
um
so it's good to have someone yeah
russians regard westerners as prey
yeah yeah it's like part of our culture
so i
i'm we'll we'll see what happens that
sounds like fun
that he had to be prayed on no it sounds
like fine but like i'll
maybe it'd be good to know somebody
especially when you go to moscow they
can show you around that is already top
of the
hierarchy so you don't have to get
pushed around because
man when i went there if i ever
separated from andre and was just by
myself
in moscow oh forget it i was like this
is
really unpleasant yeah this is really
unpleasant people and it was the winter
time too
and i was already stressed out and i was
like people are mean
little babushkas are the meanest oh yeah
would they've been through a lot
yeah they'll just bowl you over okay
like really bowl you over anyway
yeah like i've seen a lot and like what
are you doing walking slowly in a in a
crooked line
i was brighton beach is the russian
neighborhood in
brooklyn and i was in a on a bus
once uh don't judge me and this old lady
was getting off the bus slowly
and there was like a teenage russian
girl like literally poking her in the
back and just going come on come on mama
come on come on come on
and just cracking up and i it was kind
of funny she goes i'm going as fast as i
can
it was very comical but it's just like
this is like
several stand deviations away from what
is normal american behavior where it's
like do you need help getting off the
bus hope you have a nice day
pokemon come on come on mama i'll never
forget it was hilarious
yeah and that's not even yeah that
wasn't even like
russian subway yeah that was terrible
and i don't care if you can't speak
russian or
even if you even if you're from a
different area in russia they're like
you're not from moscow i can hear in
your voice i have no prob
listen i'm on twitter 25 8. if any of
these
friggin ruski's second world scum try
to assert rank on me you and i are both
zero creep agreeableness
i know how to curse in russian and i
know how to hit him where it hurts
so i am not afraid now i'm afraid of
getting my ass kicked
but i just have to be able to be like
you know faster than chris which i might
be able to maneuver
in the crowds because i'm smaller than
him he also hurt his achilles
tendon i think it's on the left foot so
you could just aim there
wham then take off deuces i told you
i told you your prey here looks like i
was the predator
yeah uh okay
well that should be fun i hope i get
some traveling in i don't know if i will
i'll just figure out where to move let
me know how miami is i will
it's gonna be uh in a month from now so
i'll message you
okay that's cool is traveling around the
states hard or is that pretty easy
i lost it on some they have the national
guard at them
at the new york city airports refusing
to let you leave until you fill out a
form
uh and i like the form it's like where
have you been where's your home address
how long you've been there
i did call him a pos
and said he's disgusting and you're
pathetic and all these horrible things
i never felt more like an american at
the same time i wasn't a badass i knew
they weren't going to do anything
but it feels great to tell the stasi
that you're just
absolute garbage um traveling has been
it's cheap uh you know because no one's
flying
uh so traveling hasn't been particularly
tough um
but there's like like the fact that it's
so uh
desolate you know makes the traveling an
issue but again that's what made austin
so fun is that i had my whole crew there
so to have a moment's piece so that was
great
hmm okay austin a
yeah i think that'll probably end up
happening yeah
it's really sad here i went for a walk
was like i've been inside i've been
inside for days i've just been
podcasting there aren't even any windows
in this room there's just like my
fake lights in front of me i was like
i'm turning into i don't know
a troll gamer yeah i'm gonna look like
mr burns when this is over
i was like i have to go for a walk and i
went for a walk and
it was just honestly it was just empty
with homeless people outside
with tents these and i was like this is
really scary
like i felt more comfortable in moscow
in the winter
that was like that's [ __ ] up yeah
getting each other going about their
business
even if they're giving you the stink eye
yeah
oh god i oh god i'm already cringing
it's gonna be a nightmare
and and chris is like oh there's some
people like fans who are like want to
show us around i'm like the fun of it is
going to be us completely fished out of
water
and i read russian like a five-year-old
i only learned how to read in college
thankfully it's phonetic but since i
speak it my the way i talk is not how
it's written
because you know colloquial is not the
same as precise uh
um language so that's gonna be fun
watching me sound out every word like
i'm
four years old with dr seuss now
i don't read at a five-year-old level
but i do read it i don't know whatever
is below that
i learned all the words when i went
there um i don't know how many i
remember but luckily it is fanatic
yeah i think you'll have a good time i
don't think it'll be miserable
just if like cute girls come up
just monitor what they're drinking i i
would not trust those russian girls as
fast as i could throw them
they are they're like the praying mantis
they are oh they're so nasty
you're with chris though yeah so yeah
who knows that's true yeah that sounds
like fun
it's gonna be fun okay so you're doing
your two books
yeah you're doing your podcast yeah and
how's the podcast going do you advertise
on that
yeah i have advertisers um it's going
really great
like it's gone up by like like 100
over last year um and it's really fun so
did you see what happened with madison
cawthorne
so madison cawthorne is this 24 25 year
old he's a congressman from he just got
elected from south carolina
and he's in a wheelchair because he was
in a car accident and when i was on
rogan i was talking about how these this
part there's different types of
bodybuilding there's one competition
called men's physique
and they're they're in board shorts
because it's all about like upper body
and proportions and joe rogan couldn't
wrap his head around it
and i said yeah they they skipped leg
day like madison cawthorne
and he heard and he challenged me to arm
wrestling but it's armed day 25
8 with him his arms are huge there's the
only way out
you're dead oh yeah yeah so the only way
to be able to win is i've had like the
the thanos infinity gauntlet and like i
like had that power
so he's coming on the show in a couple
weeks so that's the kind of thing i
wouldn't have been able to pull off i
think i think a year ago
but it's we're going to be talking about
trauma and what it's like when you're
young and you're fit and you're healthy
and overnight you'll never walk again
that's i think the more people like just
like you've been doing
when people talk about their traumatic
experiences when someone else goes
through it they're like okay
this happened to other people other
people understand how i feel
i'm not unique this is gonna suck but
there is a process
that and resources for me so instead of
you had to reinvent the wheel because
you had a very special case
but something like being a paraplegic
which i don't wish on almost anybody
it's like okay there's resources there's
this guy on
in congress he's 24 and he's in one he
looks pretty healthy and thriving
like i'm not going to sit here and be
like my life is over it's going to suck
but like
what's the steps he took to go from i'm
sure being very despondent
to being you know in a place where he's
like happy to joke about it
yeah i think that's really important you
have to find the other people who've
been through things ideally worse than
what you've been through
and then figure out what they did to
change their mindset to
survive it because it's that or like
suicide
right because you're dealing with two
things one the uncertainty and also the
actual condition
so it's exponentially worse to have
those two things together
and we all remember the first time we
got dumped and you're like oh my god
like no one knows how i feel literally
everyone knows how you feel
but like you're too kind of young and
naive to appreciate that so
it's i mean this is obviously something
that's much rarer but it'll be
interesting to talk to him about it on a
personal level
yeah that's interesting i just gotta
make sure the podcast is downstairs
and not uphill
do you what was i gonna say that
i lost i lost it it's like he lost the
use of his legs
that's stop enough
putting my fist down uh do you guys do
you get people to say
do people say no to you oh yeah what
what you know what's really funny
you know it's kind of like how bitcoin
like people who are in bitcoin like i've
been in bitcoin in five years for five
years
but like ninety percent of people don't
know what bitcoin is right so it's not
too late to join the crypto market but
you think it is because all your friends
know all about it and have known about
it
yes you and i are so up this podcasting
space we think
everyone knows about it but like no one
knows about it so i had like two
prominent names and i invited them on
and they were like an hour long with
video like i'm
i can't do that and it's like do you
unders they don't understand
this is a way for people to fall in love
with you to get to know you as a person
it's a conversation it's not let me have
the questions in advance i'm like it's a
it's a conversation it's not an
interview i'm a very softball
uh host because i'm not interested in
making people regret coming on my show
or having a bad experience i want them
to have fun i want the audience to have
fun
but they're just like i can't do this
and it's like okay
like they don't understand this whole
space
okay so i haven't had many people i've
had a few people say can i have the
questions in advance
and i'll i'll shoot generally i have a
list of i didn't have a list of
questions for you like topics
generally i have topics so that if
because i don't really know who i'm
talking to and if the conversation halts
i'm like uh
well here's something we can talk about
yeah so i've sent over that before i
haven't really had anyone that didn't
understand
but i did have after the times article
came out
a bunch of people canceled that were
kind of in the
yeah that made me so each time that
happened it made me angrier and angrier
did they give you a reason they didn't
want to be involved in any controversy
so it wasn't even it wasn't even me they
just didn't want to be
well it could have been me i don't know
maybe it was me but it was i don't want
to be involved in the controversy like i
don't want
which i kind of understand like if
you're focused a couple of them were
doctors so if you're focused on a very
specific
area and i wanted to bring attention to
what they were doing and i was like this
is
i have a fairly large platform in the
podcasting system i think they can be
helping people
and i'm trying to help people and we're
not we're not going to be talking about
politics
right but they're like we're we've been
trying to avoid controversy and so we're
just going to say no
and i was like well then you're more
interested in politics
than people than helping people which is
what i
told them like you're more interested in
politics and helping people then um
but that was before that was before i
put out my response to the times
and that helped a little bit but not
entirely
i had three events cancel
because of that yeah some people were
like don't let it bug you like
it's not good enough you'll be on pardon
i don't know they've like have you been
have you had your dad on the cover of
the sunday times and then
been insulted there like what do you
mean not
bug me what am i supposed to do yeah
and also not knowing it's against the
uncertainty like is this going to
escalate
where is this going to end that's the
problem
like and we've seen we've seen negative
media and generally speaking
it goes well but but this was a really
bad one right
like if one article if you have one
article about one topic of controversy
and then
you're all stressed out about it and
then it ends up being okay and then
there are repeat articles then the
repeat articles don't really matter but
because this was a new thing
it stressed us out really badly and then
it ended up
it ended up okay but still you can't say
just like laugh it off was because
my my emotions are like you know fight
back
like hard yeah of course but it's hard
when there's nobody to fight back
against exactly did she say anything
okay
respond anyway no okay that's probably
to her credit i mean what do you want
her to do
because you had the class what is she
gonna do right
there's nothing to do and it's gone
right it's funny because like some
people were talking about andrew cuomo
he's under investigation after what he
did with the nursing homes in new york
state where he apparently
forced them to take covert positive
patients and killed a lot of elderly
people
and i know some people were like
surprised that he's like still denying
it
and it's like what do you want him to do
apologize sorry i killed grandma
you have to at that point kind of stay
the course or else it's really going to
be worse
so she can't be like yeah these clips
were kind of misconstrued
yeah i agree
i mean she knew what she was doing yeah
she didn't know what she was doing
um i didn't know that that was happening
with cuomo oh yeah it's under
investigation now and it's very
confusing how
he went from being very valorized last
year new york state's the model to
follow i think some people's
it was the quote even though new york
had the worst per capita
death rate of anywhere on earth i
believe at the time i think i'm sure it
was 50th in america out of 50 states
and now he's under investigation and new
york times has turned on him
the washington post cnn and it's like
i've never
seen them eat their own to this extent
this quickly and i don't understand what
flipped and there's a lot of theories
but this is highly
unprecedented behavior on the part of
corporate media
over someone because at some level if he
went from being number one to being
public enemy number one
you guys had a hand in making him number
one to begin with
so it's not like this is they don't care
but it was probably some other
writer like all the writers they're not
even monitored very carefully they're
all their little separate little
factions
in the newspaper i don't think there's
any
i don't know how coordinated it even is
well that's the question well
it it was coordinated it appeared
coordinated before and it appears
coordinated now
so maybe he before he was a useful foil
against trump trump bad cuomo is the
model to follow
now that trump bad it could be biden's
good and cuomo's the enemy i don't know
but it the fact that it was such a 180
is a really big surprise
that could be it they needed a new bad
guy yeah in ontario i found out there
have been
stories about nursing homes there was
one nursing home and they took the
doorknobs off
coveted positive patients so they just
couldn't leave there
yeah this is these are things that are
happening or
you hear stories about people going in
because they weren't allowed to see
their
mother or grandparent for you know eight
months and they go and people haven't
been washed and things
like the nursing yeah that's canada so
nursing home situation is a
disaster although i've heard i've heard
that in ontario they've managed to
vaccinate
um the at-risk people in nursing homes
okay so that happened
but it's been it's been a mess and it's
not covered
the discrepancy between what's covered
and what's not covered is very strange
right now
like you you'd think the you'd think the
left that's usually up in arms about how
people are treated would be all
over some of this it's weird that
they've chosen
it's almost weird to me that they've
chosen the stance of
shut down small businesses rather than
keep them open
well i i tweeted this out like a while
ago that the far left the far left
analysis
of corporate capitalism is pretty close
to truth
because like a joe biden or i'm guessing
a trudeau will always be closer to
walmart
and amazon and target than to mom and
pop they're not these closet
stalinists or marxists or socialists
they're closet
big corporate entities you know fixing
the rules so that the big corporate
players
can have what they want and screw the
little guy i mean that's been the
i mean delaware the state we're buying
is from that's where all the credit card
companies have their
uh i believe the credit card companies
have their basis there
because the laws are so favorable
for them there's a some insane
percentage of corporations are
incorporated in delaware specifically
because of how the laws are set up there
even though it's a tiny tiny state it's
like pei
i could be wrong but i feel like one of
my dad's american businesses is in
delaware yeah
and there's like there's a problem on
the map why could he because it's not
even on the map it's tiny
there are a few states that are like
that yeah that are good for businesses
okay we should wrap it up i didn't
realize it was
it's longer than usual but you're fun
talking to and we haven't spoken in a
while so that was really fun
um where can if people don't follow you
where can people find you online
twitter.com michaelmalice and
youtube.com
michaelmaliceofficial well thank you
very much for coming on
you are welcome
[Music]
you